This is the 99% invisible breakdown of the Constitution. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elizabeth Joe. Today we're discussing articles 6 and 7. Roman, why don't we go through both articles and let's save the most important part for last. Okay, because there's a lot of unimportant parts. Less important. Go for it.
这是关于宪法的《99%隐形》深度解析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是伊丽莎白·乔。今天我们讨论第六条和第七条。罗曼，为什么我们不把这两条都过一遍，然后把最重要部分留在最后说呢？好的，因为其中有很多不那么重要的部分。没那么重要的。开始吧。
So why don't we start with Article 7? That's the ratification clause. Okay. It may be the least important to talk about today, but actually crucially important for the Constitution itself. Yeah, yeah, sure. We needed these states to vote on it, and the ratification clause says that nine states would be enough to ratify or make the Constitution itself a legitimate document. Yeah. So that in fact happened.
那我们为什么不从第七条开始呢？那是批准条款。好的。今天讨论它或许是最不重要的，但实际上对宪法本身却至关重要。对，对，当然。我们需要这些州对它进行投票，而批准条款规定，九个州就足以批准或使宪法本身成为一份合法的文件。是的。所以事实上确实如此。
It comes into effect on June 21st, 1788, when New Hampshire became the ninth state of the 13 to ratify the Constitution. So it kind of has its own clause to make sure the document is legit. Got it. Yeah, that makes sense. Okay. Yeah. So that's pretty clear. no real important Supreme Court cases on it. So let's turn back to Article 6.
它于1788年6月21日生效，当时新罕布什尔州成为了13个州中第9个批准宪法的州。所以它有点像有它自己的条款来确保这份文件是合法的。明白了。是的，这说得通。好的。是的，所以这很清楚。没有什么真正重要的最高法院判例与它相关。所以让我们转回到第六条。
Okay. Article 6 is a mishmash of a bunch of different things. So Article 6, Clause 1, talks about debts that the United States is already obligated for and still has to pay. And so why is that there? Well, you know, when the Constitution was drafted, the country still had debts and engagements that were left over from the Revolutionary War. And creditors were kind of nervous. What if you create a constitution that wipes out all of the debt? That would be pretty convenient. Got it. Got it. So in order to assuage those nervous creditors, this constitution, our constitution, actually says, don't worry, we understand that we have these debts and we are going to pay these debts. So today it's of really mostly a historical interest. It doesn't come up
好的。第六条是一堆不同东西的大杂烩。所以第六条第一款谈到了美国已经承担并且仍必须支付的债务。那么为什么会有这个条款呢？嗯，你知道的，当宪法起草时，国家仍然背负着独立战争遗留下来的债务和承诺。债权人有点紧张。如果你制定一部一笔勾销所有债务的宪法怎么办？那可就太方便了。明白了。明白了。因此，为了安抚那些紧张的债权人，这部宪法，我们的宪法，实际上是在说：别担心，我们理解我们有这些债务，我们打算偿还这些债务。所以今天它基本上只具有历史意义。它不会被提及
because we did in fact pay our debts. I will say what is interesting is that from clause one, And originally, as it was drafted, the clause said that the United States would both be obligated to pay the debts and would have the power to pay the debts. But that second part got taken out of Article 6 and put into Article 1 as part of Congress's spending authority. So that very, very important part today is actually in the larger chunk of the Constitution. We cite all the time, which is why does Congress have the ability to pass laws? And very often it's because of spending authority.
因为我们确实偿还了债务。我要说的是，有趣的是，从第一款来看，最初起草时，该条款规定美国既有义务偿还债务，也有权偿还债务。但第二部分被从第六条中移出，放入了第一条，作为国会支出权力的一部分。所以今天这个非常非常重要的部分实际上在宪法较大的篇幅中。我们一直在引用它，这就是为什么国会有权通过法律？而且通常是因为支出权力。
Wow. Well, that's really fascinating, actually. Yeah. So, you know, one little switch around made a big difference. Yeah, made a huge difference. Okay, okay, so that's the first clause. Okay, let's turn to clause three of Article 6. Do you want to read it? Okay. The senators and representatives before mentioned and the members of the several state legislatures and all executive and judicial officers, both of the United States and of the several states, shall be bound by oath or affirmation to support this Constitution. But no religious tests shall ever be required as a qualification to any office or public trust under the United States. So this is known as the no religious test clause. Great. I like this clause. Exactly. It's kind of a, you know, no religious test for anybody taking office. And in fact, it's the absence of religious tests that makes us understand that this is
哇。嗯，这真的很迷人，实际上。是的。所以，你知道，一个小小的改动就带来了巨大的差异。是的，带来了巨大的差异。好的，好的，那这是第一款。好的，让我们转向第六条第三款。你想读一下吗？好的。前述参议员和众议员以及各州议会议员，以及美国和各州的所有行政和司法官员，应宣誓或郑重声明支持本宪法。但不得以任何宗教测试作为担任美国政府下属任何职位或公共信托的资格要求。这就是所谓的无宗教测试条款。太棒了。我喜欢这个条款。没错。这有点像，你知道的，对任何担任公职的人都没有宗教测试。事实上，正是因为没有宗教测试，才让我们明白这是
successful, right? Yeah, yeah. We don't require anybody to take a religious test. Yeah. But sort of, at least formally, right. I mean, there's no formal test, but you can kind of feel it in there, the fact that the representation of other religious faiths is not super common inside of our public institutions. True, true. But there is a big difference when you were formally required to do it. And in fact,
成功的，对吧？是的，是的。我们不要求任何人接受宗教测试。是的。但至少在形式上是这样，对吧。我的意思是，没有形式上的测试，但你可以感觉得到，在我们的公共机构内部，其他宗教信仰的代表并不是超级常见。确实，确实。但当你被正式要求这样做时，还是有很大区别的。事实上，
this clause comes from traditions going back to England. So, for instance, in England in the 17th century, for example, all government officials had to take an oath that they would help establish the Church of England. Also disclaim Catholicism and the Pope. And so the idea is we have this common-in-law tradition. from England, by the time you have the colonies and the articles of Confederation, it was pretty common for government officials to be told that they had to take some kind of religious affirmation. Of course, not for the Church of England, but some kind of, I believe in God sort of test. It's notable that it's absent. It's notable for its absence.
这个条款源于可以追溯到英格兰的传统。例如，在17世纪的英格兰，所有政府官员都必须宣誓他们将帮助建立英格兰教会。还要否认天主教和教皇。所以我们的想法是，我们有这种普通法传统。来自英格兰，到了有殖民地和邦联条例的时候，政府官员被告知他们必须进行某种宗教声明是相当普遍的。当然，不是针对英格兰教会，而是某种“我信仰上帝”之类的测试。值得注意的是它缺席了。它的缺席很引人注目。
And this clause as well has very little in terms of Supreme Court interest or case law today. And that's for a totally different reason. You'll notice this is about, you know, religious freedom, essentially, right? It shouldn't matter whether you are a practicing Catholic or a Muslim or Jew to be able to take a public office. But the reason why this clause doesn't get much attention is that's because free exercise clause cases today come up under the First Amendment. Right? Rather than this clause. So not too much there as well.
而且这一条款在今天的最高法院兴趣或判例法方面也很少。这是出于完全不同的原因。你会注意到这本质上是关于，你知道的，宗教自由，对吧？担任公职不应该取决于你是一个笃信天主教、穆斯林还是犹太人。但这个条款没有受到太多关注的原因是，今天自由行使条款的案件是在第一修正案下提出的。对吧？而不是在这个条款下。所以那里也没有太多内容。
Yeah. So I noticed in a recap, you had Article 6 clause 1 and Article 6 clause 3, but we have skipped Article 6. clause two. So what is that? Well, Article 6 Clause 2 contains what's called the Supremacy Clause. Why don't you read it? Okay. This Constitution and the laws of the United States which shall be made in pursuance thereof and all treaties made, or which shall be made, under the authority of the United States, shall be the supreme law of the land. And that's referred to as the
是的。所以我注意到在回顾中，你提到了第六条第一款和第六条第三款，但我们跳过了第六条第二款。那是什么？嗯，第六条第二款包含了所谓的“至高条款”。你为什么不读一下呢？好的。本宪法以及根据本宪法制定之美国法律，以及根据美国权力已作出或将作出的所有条约，皆为全国之最高法律。这就是被称为的
supremacy clause. So why is the supremacy clause so important? Well, Historically, the Supremacy Clause responds to a very particular problem, and that is before the federal constitution, the articles of Confederation, which was the predecessor document, had no similar provision saying that federal law is supreme. And you might wonder, what does that really mean? Well, think of it this way. If you have state laws on a topic and federal laws on the exact same topic, which one are you supposed to follow? If there's no clear instruction, well, maybe you just follow whichever one you want. And that's kind of. of what happened. Before the Constitution, state courts sometimes just didn't think that federal law was binding, so they didn't apply it. They applied state law. That's kind of a problem, right? Yeah. So the supremacy clause, just with one fell swoop with this particular clause, gets rid of that uncertainty or ambiguity. The supremacy clause simply says, look, federal law, whether we mean the constitution, federal statutes, federal treaties, are supreme when it comes to any conflicting state law. So the idea here is that you have this very important structural part of the
至高条款。那么为什么至高条款如此重要呢？嗯，从历史上看，至高条款是对一个非常特定问题的回应，那就是在联邦宪法之前，《邦联条例》（作为前身文件）没有类似的规定说联邦法律是至高的。你可能想知道，这到底是什么意思？嗯，这样想。如果你在一个话题上有州法律，而在完全相同的话题上有联邦法律，你应该遵循哪一个？如果没有明确的指示，好吧，也许你只是随心所欲地遵循你想要的任何一个。而这有点像发生的事情。在宪法制定之前，州法院有时只是不认为联邦法律具有约束力，所以他们不适用它。他们适用州法律。这有点问题，对吧？是的。所以至高条款，通过这一特定条款的一举之力，消除了这种不确定性或模糊性。至高条款简单地说：看，联邦法律，无论是我们指的宪法、联邦法规还是联邦条约，在与任何冲突的州法律相抵触时都是至高的。所以这里的想法是，你拥有这个非常重要的结构部分
Constitution, that federal law is supreme. So what does that mean, practically speaking? Well, what that means is if you can think of supremacy as stating the simple fact that federal law is supreme. But arising out of supremacy is the idea that Congress now has the power when it legislates to preempt, or that really means displace or overrise. Or that really means displace or overrise. any contrary state or local law. So you can think of preemption as being based in the constitutional power of supremacy.
宪法规定，联邦法律至高无上。那么，从实际意义上讲，这意味着什么？嗯，这意味着如果你把至高性理解为陈述联邦法律至高无上这一简单事实。但由至高性产生的一个观点是，国会在立法时现在有权力先发制人，或者这实际上意味着取代或凌驾。或者这实际上意味着取代或凌驾。任何相反的州或地方法规。因此，你可以认为先发制人权是基于至高性的宪法权力。
So Congress doesn't have to exercise preemption, but when it does pass laws in this way, it's very clear that any directly conflicting state or local law has to give way. So that's kind of the genius or the simplicity of the supremacy clause. But that's the most simple part of the supremacy clause. And I take it,
所以国会不必行使先发制人权，但当它以这种方式通过法律时，非常明确的是，任何直接冲突的州或地方法规都必须让步。所以这就是至高条款的天才之处或简单之处。但这只是至高条款中最简单的部分。据我所知，
there's lots of constitution. case law based on the supremacy clause. That's right, because things can never be simple, right? Yeah, yeah. So when you think about federal law, sometimes Congress can simply say, we're going to pass a law, and this law will, in the text of the law itself, displace or preempt any similar state law. That's pretty easy. And if that were the only issue, we'd never talk about preemption.
有很多宪法。基于至高条款的判例法。没错，因为事情永远不可能那么简单，对吧？是的，是的。所以当你想到联邦法律时，有时国会可以简单地说：我们要通过一项法律，这项法律将在法律本身的文本中取代或先发制人任何类似的州法。这很简单。如果这是唯一的问题，我们永远不会讨论先发制人权。
But the problem is that Congress very often doesn't say there may be a federal law on a topic and a state law on a topic, and the federal law doesn't say anything. So in response, the Supreme Court has come up with a whole host of cases, doctrines, tests, ways of thinking about federal preemption to try and answer the question, what happens when it seems like there are federal and state laws legislating on the same topic? So what exactly is supposed to happen when there's a conflict? Well, that also is a complicated answer. So it depends on what we're talking about.
但问题是国会往往不说，某个主题上可能存在联邦法律和州法律，而联邦法律什么也没说。因此，作为回应，最高法院提出了大量的案件、学说、测试方法以及关于联邦先发制人的思考方式，试图回答这个问题：当似乎存在联邦和州法律对同一主题进行立法时，会发生什么？那么当发生冲突时到底应该发生什么？嗯，这也是一个复杂的答案。所以这取决于我们在谈论什么。
Sometimes courts will say something like, you know, there are some areas of federal law where the federal interest is so important, so extreme. We don't want the states to get involved a little tiny bit even, even if Congress hasn't specifically spoken to that area. So an interest like this would be foreign policy. We don't want the states to get involved with foreign policy, negotiating their own treaties.
有时法院会说这样的话：你知道，在某些联邦法律领域，联邦利益非常重要，非常极端。我们不希望各州哪怕插手一点点，即使国会没有具体谈到那个领域。所以这样的利益将是外交政策。我们不希望各州卷入外交政策，去谈判他们自己的条约。
That would be a bad idea. That would be a bad idea. Exactly. So those are the easy cases. but the much more frequent and difficult cases are sometimes courts have to answer, well, there's a federal law on a topic and a state law on the topic. Is it possible to comply with both state and federal law? If it's possible, maybe there is no preemption. No preemption would mean that state law and federal law are both valid.
那会是个坏主意。那会是个坏主意。没错。所以这些是简单的案件。但更频繁和困难的案件是，有时法院必须回答：好吧，某个主题上有联邦法律和州法律。是否有可能同时遵守州法律和联邦法律？如果可能的话，也许就没有先发制人。没有先发制人意味着州法律和联邦法律都有效。
But for instance, if there is a way in which the state law is an obstacle for the federal government's law to operate, or whether it's literally impossible, state law says black and federal law says white, you can't do both at the same time, then that's a case of federal preemption. So these are always case-by-case determinations. But preemption is actually really important because if you think about all of the different areas in which the federal government regulates everything from the environment, consumer protection, energy, you name it, the states also often legislate in the same areas. And what you will have are individuals or companies that say, well, I want to comply with
但例如，如果州法律成为联邦政府法律运作的障碍，或者实际上是不可能的——州法律说黑色，联邦法律说白色，你不能同时做到这两者，那么这就是联邦先发制人的情况。所以这些总是需要逐案确定的。但先发制人权实际上非常重要，因为如果你想想联邦政府监管的所有不同领域——从环境、消费者保护、能源，应有尽有——各州也经常在这些相同的领域进行立法。你会遇到个人或公司说：好吧，我想遵守
one. I don't want to comply with both or am I supposed to comply with both? And that gives rise to preemption. So of all of the areas of law that we've talked about with the Constitution, in fact, preemption is probably the most frequently used constitutional law in practice. So on the one hand, you can think of constitutional law in the courts as being on a spectrum, right? Like maybe we'd put impeachment at one end. We don't talk about it in the courts. And then preemption all the way at the other. Preemption comes up all the time because the idea of federal preemption is that it's a possible question anytime the federal government is regulating in a particular area. Right, right, which could be infinite, almost. Almost infinite. That's right. Every single area of a modern life where the states
一个。我不想两个都遵守，还是说我应该两个都遵守？这就引发了先发制人。因此，在我们讨论过的所有宪法法律领域中，实际上，先发制人在实践中最常被使用。所以一方面，你可以认为法院中的宪法法是在一个光谱上，对吧？就像我们可能会把弹劾放在一端。我们在法庭上不讨论它。然后先发制人在另一端。先发制人经常出现，因为联邦先发制人的理念是，每当联邦政府在某个特定领域进行监管时，它就是一个可能的问题。对，对，这几乎可以是无限的。几乎是无限的。没错。现代生活的每一个领域，各州
regulate very often, though not always, of course, very often the federal government is also regulating. And this situation is exacerbated by the fact that modern life continues to go on. Like there's new laws coming up all the time because there's new technology all the time and there's new things all the time to consider. That's right. So whenever you have a new policy problem, a new change in society, there's a race to regulate it or at least calls to regulate that new development in modern life. So the question is, are states going to do that job? Should the federal government do that job or should they both do that job? So one way to think about the problem of preemption is for us to pick an emerging area where both the states and the federal government are trying to regulate at the same time.
进行监管，虽然不总是这样，但非常常见的是，联邦政府也在进行监管。这种情况因为现代生活在继续而加剧。就像总是有新法律出炉，因为总是有新技术，总是有新事物需要考虑。没错。所以每当你有一个新的政策问题，社会上的新变化，就会有一场监管它的竞赛，或者至少是呼吁监管现代生活中的这种新发展。所以问题是，各州会做这项工作吗？联邦政府应该做这项工作，还是他们应该一起做这项工作？所以思考先发制人问题的一种方法是，让我们挑选一个新兴领域，州和联邦政府正试图同时对其进行监管。
And I think there's no better topic than artificial intelligence. Totally, totally. I mean, that's like huge. I don't even know what I think of it. That's right. So I can't even imagine what states and the federal government are thinking about it at this point. That's right. artificial intelligence is everywhere.
我认为没有比人工智能更好的话题了。完全是，完全是。我的意思是，这太巨大了。我甚至不知道我对它有什么看法。没错。所以我也无法想象州和联邦政府此时对它有何看法。没错。人工智能无处不在。
It's at the doctors. It's at the store. It's at school. It's at work. It's kind of a huge problem for government. And that's because AI has the potential to produce these really big benefits for society. But we've already seen that it can have all kinds of harmful effects. It can produce all kinds of major risks for society.
它在医生那里。它在商店里。它在学校。它在工作。对政府来说，这可以说是巨大的问题。这是因为人工智能有潜力为社会带来这些真正巨大的好处。但我们已经看到它可能产生各种有害影响。它会为社会产生各种重大风险。
You know, everyone's heard of AI makes up facts that don't exist that people believe and sometimes act upon. or it can make decisions about people that are really hard for us to explain. And sometimes those decisions are false or misleading. So just like any other problem in society, the states and the federal government are trying to figure out how do we regulate AI or AI systems? And that means everything from how do you regulate a chatbot that teenagers use or self-driving taxis or how do you regulate autonomous weapons when it comes to wartime.
你知道，大家都听说过人工智能编造不存在的事实，人们对此深信不疑，有时甚至据此采取行动。或者它可以对人们做出我们很难解释的决定。有时这些决定是错误或误导性的。所以就像社会上的任何其他问题一样，各州和联邦政府正试图弄清楚我们如何监管人工智能或人工智能系统。这意味着从如何监管青少年使用的聊天机器人或自动驾驶出租车，到战时如何监管自主武器，无所不包。
Oh my God. And so what kind of level of government should be regulating AI? And so should the states get out of the way altogether? Now, this seems like a very current topic, and it is. But the larger picture is an old one, and that's a question of federalism. So the narrower view we have of preemption, we're really allowing the states to engage in more experimentation for the states to say, hey, we want to try this approach. And California will always take an approach. that probably Texas will not, right?
哦，天哪。那么什么级别的政府应该监管人工智能呢？各州是否应该完全让路？现在，这似乎是一个非常热门的话题，确实如此。但宏观画面是一个古老的话题，那就是联邦制的问题。所以我们对先发制人的狭隘看法是，我们实际上允许各州进行更多的试验，让各州说：嘿，我们想尝试这种方法。加利福尼亚州总是会采取一种方法。德克萨斯州可能不会，对吧？
And vice versa. Sure. But a very broad view of preemption really is saying, you know what? We want the states to just get the heck out of the way. We want the federal government to be the primary voice in this area. So those are choices that courts have to make. There's nothing obvious about going in one direction or another.
反之亦然。当然。但对先发制人的非常广阔的看法实际上是在说：你知道吗？我们希望各州赶快让路。我们希望联邦政府成为这一领域的主要声音。所以这些是法院必须做出的选择。向任何一个方向发展都没有什么是显而易见的。
Yeah, yeah. Because this is a fast-moving and complex topic, our guest for this episode is Dr. Alondra Nelson. She's a scholar of technology and social science and a leading expert on artificial intelligence. She currently holds the Harold F. Linder Chair at the Institute for Advanced Study in Princeton. She also served in the Biden administration as the acting director of the White House Office of Science and Technology Policy. It was in that role that Dr. Nelson spearheaded what's called the blueprint for an AI Bill of Rights. We invited her to help us navigate why it's a challenge to regulate and what to think of the tug of
是的，是的。因为这是一个快速发展且复杂的话题，我们本期的嘉宾是阿隆德拉·纳尔逊博士。她是一位技术和社会科学学者，也是人工智能领域的顶尖专家。她目前担任普林斯顿高等研究院的哈罗德·F·林德讲座教授。她还曾在拜登政府中担任白宫科技政策办公室代理主任。正是在那个角色中，纳尔逊博士牵头制定了所谓的《人工智能权利法案蓝图》。我们邀请她来帮助我们探讨为什么监管是一个挑战，以及如何看待州与联邦政府在这个话题上的拉锯战，
between the states and the federal government on the topic, especially during the second Trump administration. But we start with Alondra's definition of what exactly AI is. So, you know, I usually use a modified version of the OECD definition, which is a definition that kind of 38 nation states have agreed upon. But, you know, and it's basically that these are like machine-based systems, like lots of statistics, lots of math, and that they use, they make inferences, so from different inputs, and they generate outputs.
尤其是在第二届特朗普政府期间。但我们从阿隆德拉对人工智能到底是什么的定义开始。所以，你知道，我通常使用经济合作与发展组织（OECD）定义的修改版本，这是一个大约38个民族国家达成共识的定义。但是，你知道，基本上这些都是像基于机器的系统，比如大量的统计数据，大量的数学，并且它们使用，它们进行推理，从不同的输入中产生输出。
And so the outputs are things like, you know, so-called predictions. They are things like recommendations, like your Spotify, you know, music recommendations or your Netflix recommendations. And I like to use those two examples because, you know, people have different feelings about how good or bad they think their net stream and Spotify is. And I think that's kind of a level set for AI, you know, decisions. So there are, you know, machines that are helping, you know, if we think about the theater of war, decisions about targeting people locations and the
所以输出是诸如所谓的预测之类的东西。它们是像推荐这样的东西，比如你的Spotify音乐推荐或你的Netflix推荐。我喜欢用这两个例子，因为，你知道，人们对他们的Netflix和Spotify有多好或多坏有不同的感受。我认为这对于人工智能决策来说是一个基准水平。所以有，你知道的，机器正在帮助，如果我们考虑战争剧院，关于在战争剧院中针对人员地点的决策。
theater of war. And of course, with generative AI, AI tools and systems generate content. So texts and images and sound. So that's kind of, you know, inferences made from different sets of inputs, almost all sort of data, whether those are photographs or numeric data or, you know, quote unquote, all of the internet that was taken into generative AI. and lots of different outputs. So you cross-cut that with the fact that AI systems have, like, different levels of autonomy and adaptiveness after they're deployed. So some can be very static, like, you know, a decision-making or predictive algorithm that might
当然，随着生成式人工智能的出现，人工智能工具和系统可以生成内容。比如文本、图像和声音。所以这就是，你知道的，从不同的输入集做出的推理，几乎所有的数据，无论是照片还是数字数据，或者，你知道的，所谓被纳入生成式人工智能的所有互联网数据。以及许多不同的输出。所以你将这一点与这样一个事实结合起来，即人工智能系统在部署后具有不同级别的自主性和适应性。所以有些可能是非常静态的，比如，你知道的，可能会在刑事法律系统中使用的决策或预测算法。它接收数据，并且，你知道的，它有一个硬编码的数据数据集，它以此来做所谓的预测。显然，今天，我们越来越多地。被告知诸如开放式爪子和AI代理之类的东西。所以这些是更具自主性的人工智能系统，你知道的，它们在为人们做购买决策、为他们编写代码等等。所以这是一个故意的宽泛定义，因为人工智能真的很广泛。而且我们，我认为我们在使用生成式人工智能作为我们所指的人工智能的默认设置之间摇摆不定。但它是这一整套东西。如果你跟，你知道的，一个计算机科学家或人工智能、机器学习工程师交谈，他们会告诉你，实际上，如果你考虑人工智能，人工智能的世界就像是一套俄罗斯套娃，生成式人工智能实际上是最小的，对吧？你有深度学习，你有机器学习等等。因为带有聊天机器人等功能的生成式人工智能已经成为面向消费者的工具，这确实是人工智能进入公众视野的方式，这可以说是我们思考人工智能的方式。但除此之外，还有很多其他的用例、类型、自主性和更脆弱的系统等等。是的。所以我想，当你听到这些时，这就像是一套相当技术性的定义和产品。但我想如果你在听这段对话，也许有人会觉得，嗯，我对2022年问世的ChatGPT比较熟悉。我用过好几次。但是，我真的很想知道，为什么我应该关心这个？所以对你来说，目前美国社会中正在发生的人工智能的最具变革性或真正令人担忧的例子有哪些？所以“我为什么要关心”，你知道的，我认为人们每天，特别是人们和公司，都在过分夸大人工智能。这肯定是事实。那么什么是变革性的呢？一些说法，你知道的，“为了善的人工智能”的说法是真实的，而且我认为它们要么正在发生，要么就在眼前。所以你可以考虑在医疗领域，比如人工智能系统阅读胸部
be used in the criminal legal system. It was taking in data and, you know, it has a sort of hardwired data set that it's sort of making so-called predictions against. And obviously today, we increasingly are being. told about things like open claw and AI agents. And so these are more autonomous kind of AI systems that are, you know, making purchasing decisions for people coding for them and the like. So that's a broad definition on purpose because AI is really broad. And we, I think we go back and forth from using generative AI as the default for what we mean by AI. But it's this whole
被用于刑事司法系统。它在收集数据，你知道，它有一种内置的数据集，它以此为基础来进行所谓的预测。显然，现在我们越来越听到关于开源爬虫和AI智能体之类的事情。因此，这些是更具自主性的AI系统，你知道的，它们为人们做出购买决策、编写代码等等。所以这是一个刻意给出的广义定义，因为AI的范围确实非常广泛。而且我们，我认为我们在将生成式AI作为我们所指的AI的默认含义时，一直在来回切换。但这就是整个
suite of things. And if you talk to, you know, a computer scientist or an AI, machine learning engineer, they would say to you that actually, you know, if you think about AI, the world of AI is sort of a set of Russian nesting dolls, that generative AI is actually the smallest, right? You've got deep learning, you've got machine learning and all of that. So because generative AI with things like chatbots have been made consumer-facing tools, and that's really how AI came into the public sphere, that's kind of how we think about AI. But there's a lot of other use cases and types and autonomous and more brittle, et cetera, besides. Yeah. So I think, you know, when you hear this, it's like a pretty technical set of
这一系列事物。如果你和计算机科学家或AI、机器学习工程师交流，他们会告诉你，实际上，如果你考虑AI，AI的世界就像是一套俄罗斯套娃，生成式AI其实是最小的那个，对吧？你有深度学习、机器学习等等。因此，由于生成式AI以及聊天机器人等东西已经成为了面向消费者的工具，这确实是AI进入公众视野的方式，所以我们也是这样看待AI的。但除了这些之外，还有许多其他的用例、类型、自主系统以及更脆弱的系统等等。是的。所以我想，当你听到这些时，这就像是一套相当技术性的
definitions and products. But I suppose if you're listening to this conversation, maybe someone might think, well, I'm sort of familiar with maybe chat GPT that came out in 2022. I've used it a couple of times. But like, I really want to know, like, why should I care about this? So what for you are some of the most transformative or really concerning examples of AI that are happening in American society right now? So the why should I care is, you know, I think people every day, particularly folks and companies, oversell AI. So that's certainly true. So what might be transformational? Some of the claims, you know, the AI for good claim are true and I think are on the either happening or on the horizon. So you can think about in the medical space, like an AI system reading chest
定义和产品。但我想如果你在听这段对话，也许有人会想，嗯，我对2022年发布的ChatGPT可能有点熟悉。我用过好几次。但是，我真的很想知道，为什么我应该关心这个？那么对你来说，目前美国社会中正在发生的、最具变革性或最令人担忧的AI例子有哪些？所以为什么要关心这个问题，你知道的，我认为每天都有人，特别是公司和人们，在夸大AI的作用。这当然是真的。那么什么可能是变革性的呢？一些宣称，你知道的，AI向善的宣称是真的，而且我认为它们正在发生或者即将来临。所以你可以想想在医疗领域，比如AI系统读取胸部影像
x-rays or being able to flag kind of an early stage kind of cancer diagnosis, being able to see, you know, a tumor in its very early stages. So that's transformative. And indeed, you know, if we get that right, life-saving, it is the case that we still need radiologists and we don't have enough of them. So transformational, but transformational in, potentially in the intersection of humans working with the AI, right? So, you know, other cases certainly are like in agriculture. So you can either farmers, whether it's sub-Saharan Africa, Kansas, and the United States, are using forms of computer vision, forms, you know, on a phone app that can help them
X光片，或者能够标记早期癌症诊断，能够看到，你知道的，处于非常早期的肿瘤。所以这是变革性的。而且确实，你知道的，如果我们把这一点做好，这是挽救生命的，事实仍然是我们需要放射科医生，而我们没有足够的放射科医生。所以是变革性的，但在人类与人工智能合作的交叉点上，可能是变革性的，对吧？所以，你知道，其他情况当然就像在农业中一样。所以你可以，无论是撒哈拉以南非洲的农民，还是堪萨斯州的农民，还是美国的农民，都在使用某种计算机视觉形式，某种手机应用上的形式，可以帮助他们
identify, you know, whether or not a crop is being blighted. We're using already kind of AI and the traffic flow and try to sort of direct traffic and kind of retime stoplights. So, you know, you can cut commutes or you can redirect traffic. So when these are all, as to go back to my definition, they're all systems that take an image or a data pattern or a question, make an inference and generate an output that, you know, hopefully helps to augment when humans are doing,
识别，你知道的，作物是否遭受枯萎病。我们已经在使用某种人工智能和交通流量，试图指挥交通并重新计时红绿灯。所以，你知道的，你可以缩短通勤时间或者你可以重新引导交通。所以当这些都是，回到我的定义，它们都是接收图像或数据模式或问题，进行推理并产生输出的系统，你知道的，希望有助于增强人类正在做的事情，
maybe improve what humans are doing, maybe to help humans make better decisions. So those are, I think, cool things. I mean, we just have been watching Artemis 2. You know, that is full of AI computer simulations that help them to track how they were going to do this incredible 10-day journey. Also cool. Concerning, you know, we're living with a lot of that right now.
也许能改善人类正在做的事情，也许能帮助人类做出更好的决策。所以这些，我认为是很酷的事情。我的意思是，我们刚刚一直在观看阿尔忒弥斯2号。你知道的，里面充满了人工智能计算机模拟，帮助他们追踪他们将如何完成这次不可思议的10天旅程。也很酷。令人担忧的是，我们目前正生活在其中很多事情中。
You know, we've got this kind of great race happening in the world of, you know, looking for a job, right? So you can now more easily do your resume and your cover letter using AI, but now AI systems are being used to screen your resume out. So, like, people are now sending dozens and dozens of resumes out on a given day. but they're getting screened out right away. So the downside of this is that it might filter out, you know, people out of an applicant pool before anybody ever sees your name or anybody ever, like, actually looks at your credentials and nobody will tell you why, potentially. There's some research that suggests because, you know, again, as you talk about input data
你知道，我们在寻找工作的世界里正在经历这种伟大的竞赛，对吧？所以你现在可以更轻松地利用人工智能制作简历和求职信，但现在人工智能系统正被用来将你的简历筛选掉。所以，人们现在每天发出几十份简历。但他们马上就被筛选掉了。所以这的负面影响是它可能会在任何人看到你的名字之前，或者任何人真正看你的资格之前，把人们从申请池中过滤掉，而且可能没有人会告诉你为什么。有一些研究表明，因为，你知道的，再次，正如你谈到的输入数据
and making inferences from that, and things like employment, a lot of the input data is historical data. So, you know, in fields in which you've had historic racial discrimination or gender discrimination, like if you're looking for the resume of an excellent computer scientist, then, you know, a lot of algorithms have been shown to sort of kick people out. So you're like, people are losing access to opportunities with real implications for their liberties and their rights. There's, you know, so-called predictive policing tools that the algorithm says that you should police it more because it's been policed more historically, not because there's actually new information suggesting that that should be the case. And then in the generative AI space,
并从中进行推断，在就业等方面，很多输入数据都是历史数据。所以，你知道的，在那些历史上存在种族歧视或性别歧视的领域，比如如果你在寻找一个优秀的计算机科学家的简历，那么，你知道的，很多算法都被证明会把人踢出去。所以你就像是：人们正在失去获得机会的渠道，这对他们的自由和权利有着真正的暗示。这里有，你知道的，所谓的预测性警务工具，算法说你应该加强对它的警务，因为它历史上受到的警务较多，而不是因为实际上有新的信息表明情况应该如此。然后在生成式人工智能领域，
because I live partly in New York City, the Adams administration spent, you know, nearly, I think, a million dollars on this government chat bot, this NYC bot or NYC chat. That was supposed to, you know, the idea was of it was good. It was supposed to help like small businesses navigate all sorts of city regulations, which in a place like New York City, they're voluminous. But it was telling them to violate the law. So it was giving advice like that you could like how to skim workers' tips, how to discriminate against your tenant if you're a landlord. I mean, it was fairly outrageous. And, you know, I think well beyond the kind of whimsical term, you know, hallucination that we use that, you know, often suggests that it's not a really big deal. And, you know, we shouldn't be surprised
因为我部分时间住在纽约市，亚当斯政府花了，你知道，差不多，我想有一百万美元在这个政府聊天机器人上，这个纽约市机器人或纽约市聊天。本意是，你知道的，这个想法是好的。它本意是帮助小企业应对各种城市法规，在纽约市这样的地方，这些法规卷帙浩繁。但它却告诉他们去违法。所以它给出的建议比如你可以如何克扣工人的小费，如果你是房东如何歧视你的租客。我的意思是，这相当离谱。而且，你知道的，我认为这远远超出了我们使用的那个异想天开的词“幻觉”，这个词，你知道的，通常暗示这不是什么大不了的事。而且，你知道的，我们不应该感到惊讶，我认为姆达尼政府，我想，取消了那个合同并废除了聊天机器人。但令人担忧的方面，我认为，也让你感受到，比如，我们生活中的所有地方，所有同时在某种程度上被某种形式的算法决策或管理所塑造的地点。是的。我想接近这一点的方法之一，对吧，就是不仅说：哦，这些是技术问题，而是既然你提到个人可能会感到无所适从或对正在发生的事情感到困惑的各种不同方式，你可以使用一种民权方法。而且，你知道的，当然在拜登政府中，你领导了科技政策办公室，并且你因指导白宫的《人工智能权利法案蓝图》而受到赞誉。我很希望你能多谈谈这个。这是一个政策文件。
that I think the Momdani administration, I think, canceled that contract and got rid of the chatbot. But the concerning aspects, I think, also just give you a sense of, like, all of the places in our lives, all of the sites simultaneously that are being shaped in some way by some form of kind of algorithmic decision making or management. Yeah. And I guess one of the ways to approach that, right, is to say not just like, oh, these are technical problems, but since you're mentioning like all of the different ways that individuals, might feel powerless or just confused about what's going on, you can kind of use a civil rights approach. And, you know, and of course in the Biden administration, you led the OSTP, and you're credited with directing the White House blueprint for an AI Bill of Rights. And I would love for you to talk more about that. There's a, you know, this is a policy paper.
这是一份白皮书。那么这个过程是怎样的？你是如何开始创建蓝图的？是谁在背后推动的？你和谁交谈过？是的，所以它是，你知道的，我们在大流行中期上任，我们上任时国家正在经历一场种族清算。我们正在经历一场经济危机。而且，你知道的，我认为我们这些在科技政策领域工作的人，无论是在研究方面，还是在所有这些社会关切中看到正在酝酿的事情，都知道算法空间将会发生什么。我们所有人都，你知道的，我们已经有了例子。所以，例如，关于所谓的种族主义肥皂分配器和水龙头之类的YouTube视频。对吧。
It's a white paper. So what was the process? How did you begin creating the blueprint? Like, who was behind it? Who did you talk to? Yeah, so it was, you know, we came into office in the middle of a pandemic, and we came into office as a country having a racial reckoning. We were having an economic crisis. And, you know, I think those of us who work in the science and technology policy space knew both on the research side and also kind of saw brewing amidst all of these kind of societal concerns, like what was going to be happening in the algorithmic space. And we all, you know, we were having already examples. So, for example, the YouTube videos about the, you know, the so-called racist soap dispensers and faucets. Right.
你知道，如果你有较深的肤色，你就无法让肥皂流出来，这是人工智能的一种应用。而且，你知道的，我有这个想法去做，部分原因，我想，你知道的，借鉴了许多其他例子。我的意思是，奥巴马政府在其《平价医疗法案》旁边推出了名为《患者权利法案》的东西。我想拉尔夫·纳德有一个《消费者权利法案》。所以权利法案已经被各种各样地使用，无论是政府还是公民社会的人们，作为一种在面对新技术或新的社会动态时思考权利扩张的方式。所以我们在2021年10月上任。我们在《连线》杂志上发表了一篇专栏文章。那是2021年10月发表的。
You know, if you have darker skin, you can't get the soap to come out, which is a kind of application of AI. And, you know, and I had the idea to do, in part, I think, you know, borrowed from lots of other examples. I mean, the Obama administration accompanied its Affordable Care Act with something called the Patience Bill of Rights. I think Ralph Nader had a consumer Bill of Rights. So the Bill of Rights has been used, you know, variously, both by government and folks in civil society, as a way to sort of think about a rights expansion in the face of kind of a new technology or a new social dynamic, for example. So we got into office by October of 2021. We published an op-ed and Wired. That came out in October of 2021.
我们有点使用了权利法案的框架。我们试图画出一个与国家建立的平行线，并指出在那个时期，你知道的，在18世纪80年代和90年代，美国人通过了最初的权利法案，以防范真正的权力。他们刚刚建立了一个强大的政府，对吧？我们即将庆祝独立宣言250周年然后是宪法。
And we sort of used the Bill of Rights framing. and we kind of tried to draw a parallel to the country's founding and noting that there was this time, you know, in the 1780s and 90s that Americans adopted the original Bill of Rights to guard against really a power. They just created this powerful government, right? We're about to celebrate the 250 years of the Declaration of Independence and then the Constitution.
就像我们创造了这种强大的政府技术，我们需要对其进行制约。那么在庞大而强大的政府背景下，你是如何确保我们的权利和自由、我们的机会的呢？所以我们看到了与强大的技术和推动这些强大技术的强大公司之间的相似之处，并认为有一个有用的类比，我们想要与公众一起思考，
Like we had created this kind of powerful government technology and that we needed to place a check on that. So how did you secure our rights and our liberties, our opportunities and the context of a kind of large and powerful government. So we saw a parallel with the kind of powerful technologies and the powerful companies that were pushing these powerful technologies and thought that there was a useful analogy and we're wanting to think with the public,
与美国公众一起思考，针对这些新的强大领域，什么是等效的护栏。所以我们试图将《人工智能权利法案蓝图》项目框定在一种持续的、你知道的，美国或美式传统的追求价值观的过程中，认识到我们创造的系统的不完美之处，并且，你知道的，思考我们可能会做些什么来减轻这种影响。你能告诉我们人工智能权利法案中确定的五个原则中的一些吗？当然可以。是的。所以我们，这五个原则是，伊丽莎白提到的白皮书，
with the American public about what might be equivalent kind of guardrails against these kind of new powerful domains. And so we were trying to kind of, of frame the blueprint for an AI Bill of Rights project within a kind of continuous, you know, U.S. or American tradition of aspiring to values kind of recognizing the shortcomings of the systems that we create and sort of, you know, thinking about what we might do to sort of mitigate it. Can you tell us some of the five principles that are identified in the A.I. Bill of Rights? Sure. Yeah. So we, so the five principles was, and the white paper that Elizabeth alluded to,
是在2022年10月发布的，也就是一年后。在那一年里，我们做了大量的公众参与。所以我们在《连线》杂志上的专栏文章以一个电子邮件地址结尾，你可以直接给白宫写信。这总是一个好计划。是的。所以我想我们希望更多人能采纳我们的意见，但人们确实做到了。我们做了焦点小组。我们有所谓的办公时间。所以团队中工作的每个人，包括政策通才、人工智能、计算机科学家、来自学术界、具有政府经验、具有商业经验的从事科学和技术政策工作的人。所以这是一个相当广泛的团队。我们会抽出日历上的时间专门与人们交谈。这包括高中
was released in October of 2022, so a year later. And what we did over the course of that year was a lot of public engagement. So we had that wired op-ed ends with an email address that can go direct that you can write to the White House. That's always a good plan. Yeah. So I think we wish more people had taken us up on it, but people certainly did. And we did kind of focus groups. We had what we called office hours. So everybody who worked on the team, which included policy generalists, AI, computer scientists, folks who work on science and technology policy from academia, who had government experience, who had commercial experience. So it was a pretty broad team. And we would all block on our calendar time just to talk with people. And that included high school
学生和拉比，除了总是科技公司的游说者，你知道的，但我们真的试图进行广泛的对话。所以我们，这五个，这五个原则真的是从这些对话中提炼出来的。我们不，我们并没有试图做什么新颖的事情。我们试图从将近一年的对话中汲取：我们认为最好的东西是什么？当我们作为社会进入一个更多样化的算法塑造、调解的世界时，我们应该有什么样的抱负？所以其中之一是人工智能系统应该是安全和有效的。我的意思是，这是一个非常基本且几乎是消费者权利的原则。第二，人们应该受到保护，免受算法歧视。
students and rabbis, in addition to always the technology companies, lobbyists, you know, but we really tried to have a broad conversation. And what we, so the five, the five, the five principles are really distilled from those conversations. We don't, we weren't trying to do anything novel. We were trying to sort of take from this near year of conversation, like what is the best of what we think? What are the aspirations that we should have as we move as a society into a more kind of algorithmic shaped, mediated world? So one was that AI system should be safe and effective. I mean, that's a very kind of basic and almost kind of consumer rights principle. Second, that people should have protections from algorithmic discrimination.
第三，应该有一些数据隐私的最低标准。我们仍在争论那甚至可能是什么样子。但同样，这些都是某种抱负。第四，应该有通知和解释，这样当人工智能系统被用来做出重大决策时，你应该有权知道，比如伊丽莎白你问我什么令人担忧时我谈到的那些。
Third, that there should be some modicum of data privacy. We are still fighting out what that might even look like. But again, these are kind of aspirations. Fourth, that there should be notice and explanation so that you should have a right to know when an AI system is being used to make consequential decisions, like some of those that I was talking about, Elizabeth, when you asked me what's concerning.
就像，你知道的，如果我们得到了一个糟糕的Netflix推荐，结果你看了一部算法告诉你我们会喜欢的、其实你并不真正喜欢的电影，我们在乎吗？不在乎。但是当算法和更先进的人工智能系统被用来对人们的生活做出重大决策时，他们应该知道这一点。如果他们想要一个解释，他们应该能够得到一个。最后，最后一个原则是应该有人类替代方案或后备方案，这样你，你知道的，理想情况下应该能够选择退出。我们构建了很多算法和社交媒体系统作为默认加入，而不是让人选择退出。所以你能选择退出自动化系统吗？
Like, you know, do we care if you get a bad Netflix recommendation and you end up watching movie you don't really like that the algorithm told you we're going to like, like, no. But when algorithms and more advanced AI systems are being made for consequential decisions about people's lives, they should know about that. And if they want an explanation, they should be able to get one. And then lastly, the last principle is that there should be some sort of human alternative or fallback so that you should, you know, ideally be able to opt out. We build a lot of algorithm and social media systems as opt-in, as opposed to opting people out. So can you opt out of an automated system?
你能跟真人说话，而不是陷入那种不断试图按零键找真人的电话树地狱吗？特别是当它涉及影响你生活的事情时。我的意思是，你知道的，健康保险、工作、住房。所以这些都是非常关键的事情。这就是我们想出的结果。而且它已经，你知道的，被不同类型的选民以各种方式采纳。
Can you talk to a real person instead of being kind of brought down into a circle of like a phone tree hell where you keep trying to press zero to get to a person? Particularly when it's about something that affects your life. I mean, you know, health insurance, jobs, housing. So these are really critical things. So that's what we came up with. And it's been, you know, variously sort of taken up. by different kinds of constituencies.
你能和真人通话，而不是被带入一个像电话树地狱一样的循环中，在那里你一直试图按零来转接人工吗？特别是当这涉及到影响你生活的事情时。我的意思是，医疗保险、工作、住房。所以这些都是非常关键的事情。这就是我们所想出来的。而且你知道的，它已经得到了不同选民群体的各种采纳。
It's become a kind of a civic infrastructure that is a way, I think, that allows different kinds of communities, particularly non-expert communities, to talk about why AI is important and how they want it to sort of sit in their lives and not sit in their lives. So from, you know, from an ordinary person's perspective, what would it mean to have a safe AI system? Does it mean that it's not going to make mistakes?
它已经成为了一种公民基础设施，我认为，这让不同类型的社区，特别是那些非专家社区，能够去探讨为什么人工智能很重要，以及他们希望人工智能如何融入或不融入他们的生活。因此，从普通人的角度来看，拥有一个安全的人工智能系统意味着什么？是不是意味着它不会犯错？
Or is it, you know, what do you envision as like an AI system that would follow this idea of safety? Yeah. So, you know, my friend Damon, who leads the Lawyers Committee for Civil Rights, you know, he will often say there's more laws around your toaster than around the chat bot that you might have used this morning, which is true. So we just basically don't have, certainly at a federal level, there's some action happening at the state level, but any kind of just basic consumer protection.
还是说，你心目中的安全人工智能系统应该是什么样的？是的。所以，我的朋友达蒙（Damon）领导着民权律师委员会，他经常说，有关你的烤面包机的法律，比关于你今天早上可能用过的聊天机器人的法律还要多，事实也确实如此。所以我们基本上没有，至少在联邦层面没有，虽然州层面有一些行动，但缺乏任何形式的基本消费者保护。
So I think many people are actually shocked. when they realize that when, you know, an AI company or tech company sort of ships a new model or an update of a model, that no one has looked at that. There's been no kind of third-party kind of authority that said, you know, it's met some threshold or standard of testing and that we think it should be safe and effective. So, you know, there are affordances, there are things about, particularly about generative AI. And we know increasingly from the research that you're never going to get rid of. of all of the mistakes in generative AI, certainly not in large language models.
因此，我认为当许多人意识到，当人工智能公司或科技公司推出新模型或模型更新时，竟然没有人对它进行过审核，他们其实感到很震惊。没有任何第三方权威机构说，它达到了某种测试阈值或标准，我们认为它是安全且有效的。因此，生成式人工智能确实有一些特性和功能。而且我们从研究中愈发了解到，你永远无法消除生成式人工智能中的所有错误，大语言模型更是如此。
So safe and effective systems doesn't mean that, but it does mean that one would and should expect that there should be testing on what people think would be the most obvious use cases of these technologies, right? You can't, if it's a multifunction or a multi-use technology, there are use cases, I think, that we can't, we haven't even imagined and people aren't doing yet. But I think anybody who has studied the history of technology
所以，安全且有效的系统并不意味着零错误，但它的确意味着，人们会并且应当期望，针对人们认为这些技术最显而易见的用例进行测试，对吧？你不能——如果这是一项多功能或多用途的技术，有些用例是我们甚至无法想象、人们也尚未开始做的。但是，我认为任何研究过美国科技史的人，
in the United States, even just going back to the 90s, you know, we know there's always going to be a problem with scams, scamming and fraud, always, any kind of new technology. We know historically there's always going to be a problem with forms of, you know, pornography, sexual abuse. These things are like often the first use cases for new technologies. And so, you know, that we have chatbots that are being used to nudify young people in high school or on rock or whatever.
哪怕仅仅回顾到90年代，我们都知道，诈骗和欺诈问题总是会存在，无论面对什么样的新科技，这都是必然的。从历史上看，我们知道色情内容、性虐待等问题也总是会出现。这些往往是新科技最初的用例。所以，我们看到聊天机器人在高中里被用来对年轻人进行“脱衣”处理（nudify），或者在别的地方被滥用。
We can't act like these are not harmful use cases that were not anticipated. And so it doesn't mean at all, Elizabeth, that there won't be unanticipated things or that, you know, that a chatbot won't hallucinate. But it certainly should mean that a company before releasing a product has thought through even basic historical use cases and actually thought about how they might be mitigated or that, you know, should have a conversation about some independent. stakeholder, you know, state government, you know, a civil society, I don't, you know, about how they might be mitigated. Yeah. So, you know, you'd think with all this essentially, you're sort of describing this experimentation, right, that's happening.
我们不能假装这些不是有害的用例，而且它们并非不可预见。因此，伊丽莎白，这绝不意味着不会出现意料之外的事情，也不意味着聊天机器人不会产生幻觉。但它肯定意味着，一家公司在发布产品之前，应该已经仔细思考过哪怕是最基础的历史用例，并切实考虑过如何减轻这些危害，或者应该与某个独立的利益相关者——比如州政府、公民社会等——展开对话，探讨如何缓解这些风险。是的。所以，你可能会觉得，鉴于这一切，本质上你所描述的正是这种正在发生的实验，对吧？
And we'd expect that if the government's going to do this, they also should be regulating it a lot. And the answer at the federal level has been crickets, mostly. There has been some movement. I mean, the blueprint served as a springboard for President Biden's executive order. on AI. So could you say a little bit about what the core of those concerns were in the EO? Yeah. So I think the philosophy, both for the AI Bill of Rights and for the most part for President Biden's executive order on AI, was that just because we have a new technology does not mean that
我们本应期待，如果政府要介入，他们也应该对此进行大量监管。然而在联邦层面，得到的回答大多是死一般寂静。不过也有一些进展。我的意思是，《蓝图》成为了拜登总统关于人工智能的行政命令的跳板。所以，你能否简单谈谈该行政命令中那些核心关切是什么？是的。我认为，无论是《人工智能权利法案》还是拜登总统关于人工智能的行政命令，其核心哲学都在于：仅仅因为我们有了一项新技术，并不意味着
we have to have a new social compact or a new social contract. Like you don't have to throw out every policy regulation in law because we have this new technology, as powerful as it may be. So if intentional discrimination or intentional violations of people civil lights or liberties are illegal in any other fashion, if you do that with AI, it's also illegal, right? You might have to differently figure out the mechanism or differently make the case, but the outcome is the, you know, the legality of the outcome is the same. One of the things the executive order did was ask the Department of Education to think about what, you know, you've got guidelines for children's privacy and their protection for the use of educational technology, do those need to be updated?
我们就必须建立一套新的社会契约。就像你不能因为有了这项新技术——无论它多么强大——就抛弃所有现行的政策法规和法律。因此，如果蓄意歧视或蓄意侵犯人们的公民权利和自由在任何其他情况下都是非法的，那么如果你用人工智能做出这种行为，同样也是非法的，对吧？你可能需要换一种方式来弄清机制，或者换一种方式进行论证，但结果的合法性是一样的。该行政命令做的事情之一，就是要求教育部思考，比方说，你们针对儿童隐私及其在教育技术使用中的保护已经有了指南，这些指南需要更新吗？
Or how do we need to, or do we just need to double down on what we have as you're introducing different forms of advanced AI potentially to the classroom, right? You know, the president's executive order had some, you know, directions to things like the Department of Labor. And I think differently from what the current administration has been doing, it was not just what is AI going to do to work. It was, how can government help put speed bumps, or friction or help to direct the sort of direction of travel. So you're not just potentially casting people out of work. You are helping them find other work.
或者我们需要做怎样的调整，还是说，当你们可能将不同形式的先进人工智能引入课堂时，我们只需要在现有的基础上加倍投入即可？总统的行政命令对劳工部等机构也发出了一些指示。我认为，与现任政府的做法不同，它关注的不仅仅是人工智能会对工作岗位造成什么影响。而是政府如何能够帮助设置减速带、施加摩擦力，或者帮助引导技术发展的方向。这样一来，你就不只是把人们赶出岗位。你还要帮他们找到其他工作。
You are re-skilling them. Could there be a conversation about tax incentives or other kinds of incentives to keep people on work or to help people off board or on ramp to different work, for example? The executive order, of course, also weighed in on, you know, there was a lot of concern and remains a lot of concern in the national security space. So, you know, should there be... sport control, should we be controlling where various forms of technology go? So this is still a very
你是在对他们进行技能再培训。我们是否可以探讨税收优惠或其他类型的激励措施，以维持人们的就业，或者帮助人们平稳过渡或转向不同的工作，例如？当然，该行政命令还涉及到了国家安全领域，你知道的，在这个领域过去存在、现在也依然存在着大量的关切。所以，比如，我们是否应该实施出口管制？我们是否应该控制各种技术流向何处？所以这仍然是一个非常
live conversation. Controversially, the executive order proposed that we would use the Defense Production Act from, I think, World War II originally to require that companies give the government more input and information about new, more powerful AI systems and tools that had a kind of certain threshold of capability. So it was, it might have been historically the long. longest executive order ever. Really? Yeah, I think that's right. I think it was 100 some pages, 101 or 102.
热烈讨论的话题。颇具争议的是，该行政命令提议援引最初可能源自二战时期的《国防生产法》，要求企业向政府提供更多关于新型、更强大、且达到某种能力阈值的人工智能系统和工具的输入和信息。所以，这可能是有史以来最长的行政命令了。真的吗？是的，我想是的。我记得有一百多页，101或102页。
You know, as a reformist, a reformer, I don't necessarily think that is a good thing. You know, and somebody's a bad thing. But in this case, I think it was good in the sense that it tried to be comprehensive, that the philosophy here was that this is a kind of new infrastructure. This is sort of a new operating system for a lot of the work that we do and how might we think about the ways that government can both help to accelerate potential good use cases and mitigate potential harms using the things, the tools, the mechanisms, the levers that government agencies and the executive already have.
作为一个改革派，我并不一定认为这是一件好事。当然，有人会觉得是坏事。但在这种情况下，我认为它是好的，因为它试图做到全面。这里的哲学是，这是一种新型基础设施。这有点像是我们开展的大多数工作以及我们如何思考政府能够通过使用政府机构和行政部门已经拥有的工具、机制和杠杆，既帮助加速潜在的良好用例，又减轻潜在危害的新操作系统。
We're going to take a break, but when we come back, we'll turn to how the federal government is and isn't regulating AI and how the states are filling in the gaps. So before the break, we talked to Dr. Alondra Nelson about how to think about artificial intelligence, and why it poses at risk and should be regulated. And so how did her work lead to a conversation about preemption? Well, as she's already mentioned during her time in the Biden White House, she helped create the blueprint for an AI Bill of Rights. And that blueprint became the impetus for a part of President Biden's
我们要休息一下，但回来后，我们将探讨联邦政府是如何以及如何没有监管人工智能的，以及各州是如何填补这些空白的。所以在休息之前，我们与阿隆德拉·纳尔逊（Alondra Nelson）博士探讨了如何看待人工智能，以及为什么它带来了风险并应该受到监管。那么，她的工作是如何引发关于先占原则（preemption）的讨论的呢？嗯，正如她之前已经提到的，她在拜登白宫任职期间，协助制定了《人工智能权利法案》的蓝图。而那个蓝图成为了拜登总统部分
2023 executive order on AI. And as she's already discussed, that order told the federal agencies to address the safe and ethical use of AI. Now, that's the limit of what we're going to be able to. President Biden can do. And that's because Congress has the power to legislate, not the president. So while Biden could tell the executive branch what to do about AI, he lacked the authority to actually preempt state law. Got it. And as soon as he began his second term, Trump rescinded or did away with Biden's executive order and replaced it with his own. Now, the Trump administration's approach to AI has been to turn away from a focus on safety and ethics in AI. Surprise, surprise, okay?
2023年人工智能行政命令的契机。正如她已经讨论过的，该行政命令指示联邦机构解决人工智能的安全和道德使用问题。现在，这就是我们能够做到的极限了。总统能做的事也就这么多。这是因为国会有立法权，而总统没有。因此，尽管拜登可以告诉行政部门该如何处理人工智能，但他缺乏实际先占（preempt）州法的权力。明白了。而特朗普一开启他的第二个期，就废除了拜登的行政命令，并用他自己的行政命令取而代之。现在，特朗普政府对人工智能的方法一直是转向不再关注人工智能的安全和道德。不出所料，对吧？
Right. And instead, to focus on what the federal government can do to accelerate AI development. Okay. Now, Trump's executive order has called upon Congress to use its power of preemption based in the supremacy clause to override state laws on AI. Congress so far has not responded. Okay. Which has left a lot of room for the states. And so we'll pick up our conversation there. So we have a lot of different states regulating on AI. You know, California has been in the last. lead as it often is in these areas. You know, so for example, California has just a lot of different laws on AI.
没错。取而代之的是，专注于联邦政府能做些什么来加速人工智能的发展。好了。现在，特朗普的行政命令呼吁国会利用基于最高条款（supremacy clause）的先占权力来推翻各州关于人工智能的法律。国会到目前为止还没有回应。好吧。这就给各州留下了很大的空间。因此我们将从那里继续我们的对话。所以我们有许多不同的州在监管人工智能。你知道，正如它在这些领域经常做的那样，加利福尼亚州一直走在前列。你知道，例如，加州刚刚出台了许多关于人工智能的不同法律。
For example, you know, you've got to disclose what kind of data you use if you're an AI developer, what you use to train your models. That seems like very technical, very big picture. There's also some very specific California laws that we just passed a law. You know, if you're a police department, you've got to disclose if you use generative AI when your officers, you write their police reports. That's good one. So you've got the whole range of different things.
例如，如果你是一名人工智能开发者，你必须披露你使用了什么样的数据，你用什么来训练你的模型。这听起来非常技术性，非常宏观。也有一些非常具体的加州法律，我们刚刚通过了一项法律。你知道，如果你是一个警察部门，如果你的警官在写警报时使用了生成式人工智能，你必须予以披露。这真是不错的一条。所以你有各种各样不同的规定。
So what does that mean? You talk to a lot of people in the industry. If I'm an AI developer and I want to offer my product in California or I want to offer my product in Colorado, which has an algorithmic discrimination law, what does that even mean? How does that work? Well, I mean, I think the first thing to say is that it's that we have other industries,
那么这意味着什么呢？你和很多业内人士交流过。如果我是一名人工智能开发者，我想在加利福尼亚州或科罗拉多州（该州有一项算法歧视法）推出我的产品，这到底意味着什么？这该如何运作？嗯，我的意思是，我认为首先要说的是，我们还有其他行业，
you know, where you have different kinds of regulations. So you've got like, you know, insurance is like regulation. regulated mostly by the states, for example. We've talked about a little bit consumer protection. So I think the discourse that gets used in D.C., which is its own language of its own, there's a lot of kind of like pearl clutching around the fact that you would have different laws in different states,
你知道的，在这些行业中你也有不同类型的监管。比如，保险业基本上是由各州监管的，对吧。我们刚刚也谈到了一点消费者保护。所以我想，在华盛顿特区使用的论述——它自成一种语言——对于你在不同州会有不同的法律这一事实，存在着很多大惊小怪的现象，
although the same, very same people in Washington, because they are the most adept people on, you know, what the regulatory space looks like more broadly writ large. like, you know, know that it's true all the time. You know, it's basically true. And I think there's like, you know, there's real. We use the phrase, you know, laboratories of democracy. I think there's something to that.
尽管华盛顿的那些人——因为他们是最精通整个监管领域的大局的人——知道这种情况一直在发生。你知道，这基本上是事实。而且我认为，我们用过“民主的实验室”这个短语，我认为这其中是有道理的。
I mean, you have a new technology that I think is fast moving. I think in some ideal demos, would you want just one, you know, a rule, you know, a lot of rule them all, sure, right? But we don't live in that ideal demos. And we also know that the states are much closer to the, harms. So you also have to imagine being a governor of a state or a state legislator, senator in a state, and you have people writing to you about being worried about the future of their children. You know, we had a scandal. I'm sitting here in Princeton and New Jersey about nudify apps. Like, you know, lots of just, I think, concerns about, you know, reading in the news
我的意思是，你面对的是一项快速发展的技术。我想在某种理想的民主状态下，你会希望只有一条规则统领一切吗？当然，对吧？但我们并不生活在那种理想的民主状态中。而且我们也知道，各州距离这些危害更近。所以你还得想象一下自己作为一个州的州长或州议员、州参议员的感受，你会收到人们写信表达对孩子未来担忧的信件。我们在普林斯顿和新泽西就遭遇过关于“脱衣”应用的丑闻。就像，你知道的，有很多担忧，我认为，通过阅读新闻
and experiencing young people harming themselves. You know, there's been something I saw a case reported about a potential homicide. And I think if you are a state legislator and you're hearing from constituents who've been denied a mortgage or screened out of a job by an algorithm, you can't just sit blithely and sort of not respond to that. So I think partly is just like folks are hearing it. I think that we have a new technology. What are the best ways to think about this? I mean, even with the case, you mentioned California and New York, which have done laws around kind of trying to require some disclosure and transparency from companies around harms. Texas has weighed in actually on thinking about harms and including discrimination,
并经历年轻人受到伤害。你知道，我看到过一起报道的潜在凶杀案。我想如果你是一个州议员，听到选民抱怨被算法拒绝了房贷或在求职中被筛选掉，你不能只是无动于衷、不予回应。所以我想部分原因在于人们确实听到了这些声音。我们迎来了一项新技术，思考这个问题的最佳方式是什么？我的意思是，即使以你提到的加利福尼亚州和纽约州为例，它们已经通过了旨在要求企业披露信息并提高对危害的透明度的法律。得克萨斯州实际上也权衡了对危害的看法，包括歧视，
but they've said it really has to be intent. It can't be if there's unintentional harms, you know, that they're trying to let the companies off the hook. You know, a place like Colorado has attempted the first, you know, we might think of as like an omnibus AI bill that covers lots of things, you know, including sort of harms to young people, deep fakes, discrimination. And these are all, these are like I've just named three different approaches. And it's not clear which one of those is the best one or which one's going to be most efficacious. And I think it's worth actually letting states do this, you know, finish the work of implementing these laws and actually find out. I just don't think that the harms are more likely to be on the side of not doing anything at all,
但他们表示，这必须是蓄意的。如果是非蓄意的伤害，不能把企业从责任中解脱出来。像科罗拉多州这样地方，尝试推出了第一部我们可能会认为是综合性（omnibus）的人工智能法案，涵盖了许多方面，包括对年轻人的伤害、深度伪造（deepfakes）、歧视。而这些，我刚刚列举了三种不同的方法。目前还不清楚其中哪一种是最好的，或者哪一种最有效。我认为实际上值得让各州去这样做，完成这些法律的实施工作并找出答案。我只是认为，危害更有可能来自于什么都不做，
rather than trying to do a couple of, you know, different innovative strategies in different states to see. And then, you know, because there's been no federal law, there's obviously just this vacuum in the states and there's a lack of clarity. And, you know, I think there's been the D.C. conversation, the Trump administration conversation has been, or discourse has really been, well, it's creating confusion. And I think what's actually creating confusion is the lack of any kind of federal guidance. Yeah. It's actually the states that are trying to sort of bring clarity to chaos. I mean, if the states are the appropriate front line for figuring this stuff out, is the ideal form of that to eventually roll up into some kind of federal regulation that makes sense? Sure. I mean, I think what the state patchwork does is test things out. Some things will work. Some things will fail horribly. I think it also creates some kind of the, you know, the so-called patchwork. I think kind of creates some upward pressure because we're, When exactly to your point, Roman, when enough states act, federal policy or norms become, as the patchwork gets woven together, become kind of implicit.
而不是在不同的州尝试几种不同的创新策略来看看效果。而且，由于一直没有联邦法律，各州显然存在真空，缺乏清晰度。我认为华盛顿特区的对话、特朗普政府的对话或论述一直是：这造成了混乱。而我认为真正造成混乱的是缺乏任何形式的联邦指导。是的。实际上是各州正试图在混乱中带入清晰度。我的意思是，如果各州是弄清楚这些事情的合适前线，这种形式的理想状态最终是不是要演变成某种说得通的联邦监管？当然。我的意思是，我认为各州的拼凑做法就像是一场测试。有些东西会奏效，有些东西会彻底失败。我认为它也产生了一些，所谓的“拼凑”，我认为它产生了一些向上的压力，因为我们正处于，
And I think it puts more pressure on it for the federal government to actually do something explicitly. I would also, like, if we widen the aperture just slightly broadly from like the AI companies that, you know, like that we're talking about now to social media, the social media example, which gives us another, you know, 15, 10 years more to think about. we've seen the utter failure, right, of the federal government to be able to legislate in that space. And to the extent that we've got anything that looks like regulation or law or governance in that space, it's coming out of these lawsuits, like the lawsuits that we saw early, you know, that were decided a few weeks ago around, you know, meta and YouTube. And so I think there's also, I think if you are a state level, you know, executive, if you're a governor or a state, state legislator, you're like thinking it back about that example and just thinking, we can't wait and do this again.
罗曼，正如你所说，当足够多的州采取行动时，随着拼凑的布料被编织在一起，联邦政策或规范会变得不言而喻。我认为这给联邦政府带来了更大的压力，迫使其真正采取明确的行动。我也想，如果我们把视野从我们现在讨论的人工智能公司稍微放宽一点到社交媒体上，社交媒体的例子为我们提供了另外15到10年的思考时间。我们已经看到了联邦政府在这一领域立法的彻底失败，对吧？而且，就我们在该领域拥有任何看起来像监管、法律或治理的东西而言，它们都来自于这些诉讼，比如我们早些时候看到的、几周前刚裁决的围绕Meta和YouTube的诉讼。所以我想，如果你是一个州级行政长官，如果你是一位州长或州议员，你也会回想起那个例子，然后觉得我们不能坐视不管，再经历一次这种局面。
You know, the other, you know, as I said, the states are close to the harms, they're hearing from constituencies. The way that we've been governing, if you think about the social media model, I mean, the young woman who was the plaintiff, and I think in the META case, she's 20 years old.
你知道，另一个原因，正如我所说的，各州离危害很近，它们听到了选民的呼声。我们一直在进行的治理方式——如果你想想社交媒体的模式——我的意思是，那个作为Meta案中原告的年轻女性，她今年20岁。
I mean, this happened eight years ago or something. She was, you know, a child when this happened. And so using liability and legal cases puts us quite far away. from the harms. And I think the states can be much closer. Yeah, just to back up for a moment, by way of explanation, you're referring to the social media trials that are happening in California, where basically the state's attorney generals and private plaintiffs are suing, arguing that social media platforms are harmful products, which has a long storied history of legal liability
我的意思是，这件事发生在八年前左右。当这件事发生时，她还是个孩子。因此，利用责任追究和法律诉讼使我们离
in the United States. And actually, they're using the legal playbook of big tobacco. You know, we kind of shut down big tobacco because we argued that the companies knew that these were harmful products and you sold them anyway. And that has proven so far to be successful in the social media space. So I guess we could think of perhaps, you know, AI. Some of these products are going to be dangerous and maybe we'll do that. Of course, I think you're right. I'll say that this is a backup, right? We don't want to wait for the bad use case for people to be harmed. I mean, the nice thing about regulation is you can be proactive and say, we think the. this is going to happen or it is happening and we want to affect as many people as we can within the
危害相当遥远。而我认为各州可以离得更近。是的，为了稍微做点背景补充说明，你指的是正在加州进行的社交媒体诉讼，基本上是由各州的检察长和私人原告提起诉讼，认为社交媒体平台是有害产品，这在美国法律责任史上有着悠久的历史。
state or within the country. My question is really more about what about the companies? Not that I feel too bad for them. But if you're a company, it's pretty burdensome, I would think, that you've got to look at every state and see like what is every state doing. So I would imagine that, you know, their first choice is no regulation, right? But their second choice must be federal regulation. No? Yeah, I mean, I would disagree with that a little bit. I mean, let's have a friendly quibble about this. I mean, I think that the compliance burden argument, I think, is a bit overstated by companies, right? You know, that that's just what companies do in their own interest in their lobbyists. So, you know, right. And as I said, you know, I already mentioned, I think companies
事实上，他们正在使用大型烟草公司的法律 playbook。你知道，我们之所以能关停大型烟草公司，是因为我们辩称这些公司明知这些是有害产品，但你还是把它们卖了。事实证明，这在社交媒体领域迄今为止是成功的。所以我想我们可以认为，也许，人工智能。其中一些产品将是危险的，也许我们会这样做。当然，我想你是对的。我要说的是，这只是最后的备选方案，对吧？我们不想等到发生了坏的用例、人们受到了伤害才行动。我的意思是，监管的好处在于你可以具有前瞻性，可以说，我们认为这将会发生或者正在发生，我们希望在州内或国内尽可能多地影响人们。我的问题其实更关于企业。倒不是说我多心疼它们。但如果你是一家企业，我认为你必须审视每一个州，看看每个州都在做什么，这会是相当繁重的负担。所以我想象，它们的第一个选择是没有监管，对吧？但它们的第二个选择一定是对联邦监管的渴求，对吗？
already in other policy spaces are navigating like different consumer protection regimes for different states, different employment laws, different privacy frameworks. I mean, you know, there's a, the state of Illinois has this pretty strong biometric policy, you know, regime. And yet, you know, companies were still, Clearview was still selling its facial recognition technology data set, for example. So I think that the language from companies and lobbyists that say that state AI laws are like uniquely burdensome or specially burdensome, I think doesn't really hold up when you think about these other examples of these other policy spaces. The other thing I would say is that I think what your question, which is a common question, an important one, presumes,
不，我的意思是，我对这一点有点不同意。我的意思是，让我们对此进行一次友好的辩论。我认为，合规负担的论点被企业夸大了一点，对吧？你知道，这只是企业为了自身利益和游说集团在做的事情。所以，你知道的，对吧？正如我所说，我之前已经提到过了，我认为企业在其他政策空间中已经在应对不同州的消费者保护制度、不同的就业法律、不同的隐私框架。我的意思是，伊利诺伊州有相当严格的生物识别政策制度。然而，Clearview公司仍然在出售其面部识别技术数据集，例如。所以我想，来自企业和游说者的那种声称各州的人工智能法律具有“独特负担”或“特别负担”的言论，当你考虑到这些其他政策空间的例子时，其实是站不住脚你的。我还要说的是，你的问题——这是一个常见且重要的问题——所预设的是，
is that like, if the states don't have a law, there's no other governance or pressure being applied on the direction of AI governance, which certainly in the Trump administration is not true. So, you know, so, okay, maybe you have to, you don't want to deal with California or Colorado, but you've got a Trump administration that's saying, we're changing tariffs every day.
如果各州没有法律，就不会有其他治理或压力被施加在人工智能治理的方向上，这在特朗普政府时期显然是不真实的。所以，好吧，也许你必须，你不想应付加利福尼亚州或科罗拉多州，但你有一个特朗普政府在说，我们每天都在改变关税。
You know, we've gone from Liberation Day to not Liberation Day back and forth. So companies are dealing with that, including AI companies. You've got a Trump administration that is saying we're uncertain about we don't like immigration. We're uncomfortable with science and tech immigration. If you want to bring a new technology talent AI company, you're going to have to pay $100,000 per visa if we allow you to have one to bring some, you know, a talented engineer from France or, you know, Korea or something. And then they're also intervening in business. So, you know, we've got. We've got. the U.S. taxpayer is a shareholder in NVIDIA,
你知道，我们经历了“解放日”到“不是解放日”的反反复复。所以企业不得不应对这些，包括人工智能公司。你有一个特朗普政府在说，我们对移民感到不确定，我们不喜欢移民。我们对科学和技术移民感到不适。如果你想引进一个人才密集型的人工智能公司，如果你想从法国、韩国等地引进一位有才华的工程师，如果我们允许的话，你将不得不为每份签证支付10万美元。然后他们还在干预商业。所以，你知道的，我们有。我们有。美国纳税人成了英伟达的股东，
where a shareholder in Intel. So the compliance burden question, I think, is much too narrow, given all of the different ways in which companies are being asked to respond to a kind of broad spectrum of AI governance. Yeah, and let's not forget, I should say, you know, the federal government and all of the state governments are huge customers, right?
我们成了英特尔的股东。因此，考虑到企业被要求应对的广泛的人工智能治理谱系中的各种不同方式，合规负担的问题实在是太狭隘了。是的，别忘了，我应该说，联邦政府和所有州政府都是大客户，对吧？
You know, customers can demand changes if they want. procurement is an excellent vehicle. I mean, you know, Governor Newsom just signed this executive order that I think really leaned into that, including not only safety issues, but issues around discrimination and civil rights and liberties, which I thought was fantastic. So we've talked a lot about sort of granular harms that are potentially happening or are happening. But I do want to talk about your thoughts on what's on the horizon, the AI horizon. There seems to be this race to develop AGI or artificial general.
你知道，如果客户愿意，他们可以要求改变。政府采购是一个极好的工具。我的意思是，纽森州长（Governor Newsom）刚刚签署了一项行政命令，我认为它真正倾向于这一点，不仅包括安全问题，还包括歧视、公民权利和自由等方面的问题，我认为这棒极了。所以我们已经讨论了很多关于可能正在发生或已经发生的细颗粒度危害。但我确实想谈谈你对地平线上的事物的看法，即人工智能的地平线。似乎存在着一场开发AGI（通用人工智能）或人工通用智能的竞赛。
intelligence. So the idea would be like not like, please find all the cats in this picture or write my high school essay on Pride and Prejudice. It's like an all-purpose, sophisticated AI with autonomy. Now, you've spoken to a lot of people in tech. I've spoken to a few. It seems like some people in the AI policy world are extremely worried about this. Like we could create something that gets totally out of control, develops like a biological weapon, takes over our defense systems. How concerned are you about this? As a, as a, at some, and then an object of regulation. So I'm concerned about it as I think some people are quite invested in the name and what the name means.
所以这个想法将不再是——请找出这张图片中的所有猫，或者写一篇关于《傲慢与偏见》的高中论文。它是一种具有自主性的全功能、复杂的人工智能。现在，你和科技界的很多人谈过。我也和一些人谈过。似乎人工智能政策界的一些人对此极其担忧。就像我们可能会制造出完全失控的东西，开发出像生化武器这样的东西，接管我们的防御系统。你对此有多担心？作为一个监管的对象。所以，我对此的担忧在于，我认为有些人非常执着于这个名称以及这个名称的含义。
So people are quite invested in whether it's super intelligence or AGI. I'm not at all invested in the name and I don't really care. So it keeps me out of some fights, but probably also keeps me out of some parties. I don't know. But I do think that, you know, I prefer to use. the phrase like advanced AI. Like there are significant concerns about advanced AI. So example, if we think about the Doge early, you know, last year in the Trump administration, and part of what the reporting and Wired and elsewhere was suggesting is that Doge was breaking the Privacy Act of 1974,
所以人们非常纠结于它是超级智能还是AGI。我一点也不纠结这个名字，我根本不在乎。所以这让我免于陷入一些争端，但也可能让我错过了某些派对。我不知道。但我确实认为，我更愿意使用诸如“先进人工智能”这样的短语。比如，人们对先进人工智能有着重大的担忧。例如，如果我们想想特朗普政府早些时候（去年）的Doge，根据《连线》（Wired）和其他地方的报道和暗示，Doge正在违反1974年的《隐私法》，
which said that a lot of interagency organizations could not share data, in part because you don't want the federal government to have administrative data about you from health and human services, from Fannie Mae, from whatever, to be able to put into this kind of large surveillance kind of panapticon. And I think what like powerful AI systems do is allow the interoperability of that data and the sort of discovery potential of associations that are dangerous, things that we could never possibly know about ourselves or about others. So that's like not even a. GI, right? But that's just like sort of a powerful extreme. So if you imagine a system having access to data about everyone in the United States, everyone in the world, being able to
该法规定许多跨机构组织不能共享数据，部分原因是你不想让联邦政府拥有来自卫生与公众服务部、房利美（Fannie Mae）等机构的关于你的行政数据，从而能够将这些数据汇入这种大规模的监控全景敞开机中。我认为强大的 AI 系统所做的是允许这些数据的互操作性，以及发现潜在的危险关联——那些我们永远无法通过自身或他人了解的事情。所以这甚至不是AGI，对吧？但这只是一种强大的极端情况。所以，想象一下一个系统可以访问关于美国乃至全世界每个人的数据，能够
sort of constantly be evaluating that data, running that data, and then making decisions. And again, you know, I mentioned at the beginning, the various forms of the, you know, autonomy or not of different AI systems and to do it autonomously. So imagine not just all of the, you know, open claws, not all the little lobster claws of various agents, but like a really big claw, like a really powerful independent agent sort of acting in the world. And so we've got, you know, there's been some reporting and I've seen, you know, and some people, you know, discussing on social media, things like, you know, I used this agent and it wiped out my entire hard drive or it deleted all of my emails or that, right? You know, and that's, you know, that's happening.
不断评估这些数据、运行这些数据并做出决策。再次强调，正如我在开头提到的，不同人工智能系统的自主性或非自主性的各种形式，以及如何自主地做到这一点。所以想象一下，不仅仅是所有这些，你知道的，Open Claws，不仅仅是各种代理的小龙虾爪，而是一个真正的大爪子——一个在世界上行事的真正强大且独立的代理。所以我们看到，有一些报道，我也看到，有些人——一些人在社交媒体上讨论诸如——我使用了这个代理，它抹掉了我的整个硬盘，或者它删除了我所有的电子邮件——诸如此类的事情，对吧？你知道，这正在发生。
And we're not imagining an AI agent that was sentient at all knowing. and like Dill decided that it was going to wipe out all of your email because you work too hard or because it doesn't want you to work or whatever. Those are just powerful systems that we're learning to you. So then you can imagine potentially a system having a bit more intentionality, a bit more sort of understanding of its stakes in being more powerful. The question then becomes, and I think this is where we trip ourselves up, well, how do you regulate that?
我们并不是在想象一个有知觉、全知全能的AI代理，它突然决定要删掉你所有的电子邮件，因为你工作太努力了，或者因为它不想让你工作，等等。这些只是我们正在学会使用的强大系统。所以你就可以想象，一个潜在的系统可能具有更多的意图性，对它在变得更强大时的利害关系有更多的理解。问题随之而来——我认为这也是我们自我绊倒的地方——好吧，你该如何监管它？
It's just so powerful, what are we going to do? And before you get there, you need to. to imagine that companies can actually be told not to build a thing. You know, I mean, you can't tell them not to, or they can be told that they can't ship a thing. You can't tell a company what to create, but you can certainly say you can't ship this out into the world without certain controls. Like someone needs to be able to have a kind of final decision on whether or not it ships or to be able to turn it off and on or you can only run it for a few hours or it can only have
它太强大了，我们该怎么办？但在你到达那一步之前，你需要想象公司其实是可以被告知不要制造某种东西的。你知道，我的意思是，你不能告诉它们不要创造，或者它们可以被告知不能发布某个东西。你无法告诉一家公司该创造什么，但你绝对可以告诉它们，在没有某些控制措施的情况下，你不能把这东西投放并发布到世界上。需要有人能够对它是否发布做出最终决定，或者能够将其关闭和开启，或者你只能运行它几个小时，或者它只能访问
so much access to so much compute or so much data, you know, and we're not having those kind of, I think, system-wide conversations. And, you know, to go back to where, you know, the kind of subject of the broader conversation, I mean, that is where you would want a smart, prudent, federal government to sort of weigh in, right? That's where, you know, at that level of kind of nuance and both kind of level of abstraction and power,
有限的计算资源或有限的数据，你知道的，而我们并没有在进行那种全系统范围的对话。并且，为了回到我们更广泛对话的主题，我的意思是，那正是你希望看到一个明智、审慎的联邦政府介入的地方，对吧？正是在那种细微差别、抽象水平和权力水平上，
you might want there to be some sort of federal, I think law or legislation or guidance. When we come back, Dr. Nelson explains her vision for finding a consensus on AI regulation. And whether she's optimistic, the government will figure this out. I mean, you've developed this idea of a kind of thick alignment when it comes to AI governance. Could you talk more about what thick alignment is and how that translates to regulation? Yeah, so there's a wonderful writer, Brian Christian, who has a really, you know, important book that I would, come in to people called the alignment problem that is really writing about the first, the kind of
你可能希望某种联邦层面的法律、立法或指导能够存在。当我们回来时，纳尔逊博士将阐述她对寻找人工智能监管共识的愿景。以及她是否对政府能搞定这件事保持乐观。我的意思是，在人工智能治理方面，你提出了“深度对齐”（thick alignment）的概念。你能多谈谈什么是深度对齐，以及它是如何转化为监管的吗？是的，有一位杰出的作家布赖恩·克里斯蒂安（Brian Christian），他写了一本非常重要的书，我向大家推荐，书名叫《对齐问题》（The alignment problem），它真正记录了我们所说的人工智能安全的第一批、
early years of what we, what some people call AI safety, which is basically just like how do we explain them, how do we interpret what they're doing, how do we demonstrate that they're safe to the extent possible. And, you know, it was very much a kind of technical sense of thinking about alignment. So, you know, the system says that it's supposed to identify at 98% with a margin of error of two or three percent, you know, these people in a facial recognition technology system. And for all intents and purposes, you would say that system is aligned, right? But we know the system is misidentifying people. We know in the Detroit metropolitan area that there have been more than half a dozen people
早期的岁月，这基本上就是——我们如何解释它们，我们如何解释它们在做什么，我们在多大程度上证明它们是安全的。而且，这在很大程度上是一种技术意义上的对齐思考方式。所以，你知道，系统声称它应该在面部识别技术系统中以98%的准确率、2%到3%的误差范围识别出这些人。为了所有的实际目的，你会说该系统是对齐的，对吧？但我们知道该系统在错误识别人们。我们知道在底特律大都市区，有超过半打的人
misidentified by facial recognition technologies that someone, somewhere in the development and deployment queue said, this is aligned. Like this product works, right? And so as we're thinking about AI systems and advanced AI systems, it's not just whether or not they kind of work technically. What happens when you or what can we anticipate or not anticipate when you deploy them? And how do we create a process or an understanding that allows us to be thinking about alignment as something that needs to happen fairly continuously over time? And also that's something that needs to happen in conversation with the values. of different communities and different societies.
被面部识别技术错误识别，而开发和部署队列中的某人、某处曾说过：这是对齐的。就像这个产品能正常工作一样，对吧？因此，当我们思考人工智能系统和先进人工智能系统时，这不仅仅关乎它们在技术上是否能运转。当你部署它们时，我们会或不会预见到什么？我们如何创建一个过程或理解，使我们能够将对齐视为一件需要随着时间的推移相当持续地发生的事情？并且这也是一件需要与不同社区和不同社会的价值观进行对话的事情。
So alignment is not, so by thick alignment, I am taking up the work of, you know, the philosopher Gilbert Ryle, but also the anthropologist, Clifford Gererts, who was a professor here at the Institute of Advanced Study in Princeton, where I am, who has this very famous sort of essay and the concept of thick description,
所以对齐不是——因此，通过“深度对齐”，我借鉴了哲学家吉尔伯特·赖尔（Gilbert Ryle）的工作，还有人类学家克利福德·格尔茨（Clifford Geertz）的工作，他是普林斯顿高等研究院的教授（也就是我目前所在的地方），他有一篇非常著名的关于“深描”（thick description）概念的论文，
like that you don't really understand the world until you've really thought to understand contextually, deeply, what it means. How do you describe it deeply? And so my provocation to AI safety researchers and my collaboration actually so it's not just a critical work
大意是你直到真正深入、语境化地理解了它的含义，才真正理解了这个世界。你如何进行深描？因此，我对人工智能安全研究人员的挑衅以及我的合作——事实上它不只是批判性的工作——
is sort of what does it mean to like alignment is important. Safety, explainability, interpretability, all the things that you might put in that bucket are really important and are an important and taken together or are an important solution set for some of the harm mitigation that we might want to do
就是说，对齐是很重要的。安全、可解释性、可解释性（interpretability），所有你可能会放进这个大熔炉里的东西都非常重要，并且它们结合在一起是一套重要的解决方案，可以帮助我们在人工智能领域实现一些危害缓解。
in the space of AI. But what does it mean to do that in a way that takes seriously the different contexts in which these tools might be used, the different values. So if you think about, you know, Anthropic has created a constitution for AI, for example, like, you know, who gets to weigh in on that? And are those the values that I want or others want? You see this kind of value conversation coming up also and even some of the Trump administrations kind of the way that they frame sort of, quote unquote, ideological bias in AI. Like, who gets to decide what's biased in AI? There's a technical question about bias.
但这意味着以一种认真对待这些工具可能被使用的不同语境、不同价值观念的方式来做这件事。所以如果你想想，比如，Anthropic公司为人工智能制定了宪法，例如，谁能参与其中？这些是我想要的价值观还是其他人想要的价值观？你会看到这种关于价值观的对话正在涌现，甚至在特朗普政府对所谓人工智能中“意识形态偏见”的构架方式中也能看到。比如，谁来决定人工智能中什么是偏见？关于人工智能中的偏见，
in AI, but who gets to decide sort of what is a biased chat bot? So I think we just need to have a conversation we're not having about what it means to try to come to a rough consensus values to the extent that's even possible to try to have, you know, high level values to make decisions about these technology. So I think the AI Bill of Rights was one of the ways that we were trying to point to that. But certainly I think state laws are another way. I mean, you have state sort of saying, I mean, that you might think of those or as examples of thick alignment. Like, this is what our constituency cares about. And this is where we're going to lean in on in the regulatory space with regard to AI. The other stuff, maybe we don't care about so much.
有一个技术问题，但谁来决定什么样的聊天机器人是有偏见的？所以我想我们只是需要进行一场我们目前没有进行的对话，探讨在尽可能的情况下，达成粗略共识的价值观意味着什么，从而拥有高水平的价值观来对这些技术做出决策。所以我认为《人工智能权利法案》是我们试图指出这一点的方式之一。但当然，我认为各州的法律是另一种方式。我的意思是，各州都在表达——你可以将这些视为深度对齐的例子。比如，这是我们的选民所关心的。这就是我们在人工智能监管领域将要深入投入的地方。至于其他方面，也许我们没那么关心。
But like, I don't even know if I have thick alignment with President Trump as like a human. You know what I mean? Like, it seems harder and harder to have it, you know, like when you're talking about all these hypothetical uses of this stuff. And like if something like a program is supposed to have inherent, you know, human values. I, I, I, I, I don't know, I, I don't know. A lot of those don't feel shared right now. No, I think that's right. I will say, you know, one of the things I've been doing since I left, so the AI Bill of Rights comes out in October of 2022, 2022.
但就像，作为一个活生生的人，我甚至不知道自己是否与特朗普总统有着深度对齐。你知道我的意思吗？就像，当你在谈论所有这些假设的用法时，这种对齐似乎变得越来越难。而且如果像某个程序被认为具有内在的、人类的价值观。我，我，我，我不知道，我不知道。其中许多价值观现在看起来并不共享。不，我认为这是对的。我要说的是，你知道，自从我离开后我一直在做的一件事是——所以《人工智能权利法案》是在2022年10月发布的，2022年。
And I've been since that time following its afterlives. And some of its afterlives, I think, Roman, to your point, have been in red states. So there's been an Oklahoma AI Bill of Rights introduced as a bill. You know, it didn't succeed ultimately, but it contained all of the five principles that we discussed previously, plus a few more that were really good and actually quite stronger than some of the things that we suggested. More recently in November and Florida, Governor DeSantis introduced a Florida AI Bill of Rights, which contains within it all of the five principles that we have and lots of other things besides deep fakes, you know, child sexual abuse of imagery, a really nice clause. that was around health insurance and not being able, you know, being able to get a decision around algorithmic uses of health insurance. So I totally take your point, Roman, but it's also
从那时起，我一直在关注它的后续影响。罗曼，正如你所说，其中一些后续影响，我认为发生在红州。比如俄克拉荷马州曾提出过一项AI权利法案。你知道，它最终没有成功，但它包含了我们之前讨论过的所有五项原则，以及另外几项非常不错的原则，甚至比我们建议的一些内容还要更有力。最近在11月和佛罗里达州，德桑蒂斯州长推出了佛罗里达州AI权利法案，其中包含了我们拥有的所有五项原则，以及除了深度伪造之外的许多其他内容，你知道，关于儿童性虐待图像，还有一个非常好的条款，是关于健康保险的，能够让人对健康保险的算法应用做出决定。所以罗曼，我完全理解你的观点，但同时
clear that there are a few things that we agree are wrong or that we don't want that are like suboptimal for society. And so I take, I think you're exactly right, but I also take some comfort in these Bill of Rights alignments that pop up here and there. You sound optimistic about the future of AI regulations. Is that right? I'm not optimistic about, am I optimistic about regulation? I don't know. I mean, I think if we look at the history of technology policy at the federal level and the Congress, I mean, we, Elizabeth, correct me if I'm wrong, but I think, you know, it's maybe not been since like the Communications D, since the Act of 1996 that we've passed anything like a technology law. Like, you know, that's a long time. That's a generation. So I'm not optimistic in that. sense. I think I'm optimistic with, you know, some people are calling it the tech backlash, and I don't call it that. You know, I don't, I don't like that framing. But there's a growing public empowerment to speak about what people want and don't want with regards to the way that
显然，有些事情我们都认为是不对的，或者是不想要的，它们对社会来说是次优的。因此，我认为你的看法完全正确，但同时我也从这些不时出现的权利法案的共识中得到了一些安慰。你听起来对AI监管的未来很乐观。是这样吗？我对……我对于监管持乐观态度吗？我不知道。我的意思是，如果我们回顾联邦层面和国会的技术政策历史，伊丽莎白，如果我错了请纠正我，但我认为，你知道，自从1996年《通信端正法》以来，我们可能就没有通过过任何类似的技术法律。就像，你知道，那是很久以前的事了。那是一代人的时间。所以在这个意义上，我不乐观。我认为我感到乐观的是，你知道，有些人称之为技术反弹，而我不这么叫它。你知道，我不喜欢那种框架。但公众对于表达自己对以下事情的期望和反对的赋权正在不断增长，那就是
AI systems are being developed and deployed. So when I first started working, you know, and sort of big data and then, you know, as it became AI, you know, policy and research. That's how you date yourself. I know. I know. You say big data in a room and people kind of like the young cringe. They're just like, oh, big data is so cringe. So, you know, you would sit in rooms and say people can't possibly understand. I mean, even now you hear people saying, you know, if folks don't have, you was here in D.C.
AI系统的开发和部署方式。所以当我刚开始工作时，你知道，做大数据，然后，你知道，当它变成AI时，做政策和研究。这就是暴露年龄的方式。我知道。我知道。你在一个房间里说大数据，人们就会感到有点尴尬。他们就会觉得，哦，大数据太尴尬了。所以，你知道，你会坐在房间里说，人们根本不可能理解。我的意思是，即使现在你听到有人说，你知道，如果人们没有，你当时在华盛顿
actually, when I was working in Washington, you know, if you don't really have a PhD, if you're a staffer on the hill and you don't have a degree in machine learning or AI, like, how could you possibly even begin to like offer guidance on how we should govern this technology? So, of course, you don't want people who know nothing about AI to be governing AI. But I've been encouraged by the fact that the public has demonstrated that it is not true that you have to have a PhD in AI to be able to say something about the AI governance space. So you see it in the space of governance center, of data center. So people have really, you know, that's a place where like AI governance and policy is quite tactile, right? So it is in communities. It is about their water.
事实上，当我还在华盛顿工作时，你知道，如果你没有博士学位，如果你是国会山的一名工作人员，并且你没有机器学习或AI的学位，那么你怎么可能开始为我们应该如何治理这项技术提供指导呢？所以，当然，你不会希望对AI一无所知的人来治理AI。但让我感到鼓舞的是，公众已经证明，要对AI治理领域发表意见，并不非得拥有AI博士学位，这种说法是不成立的。所以你在治理中心、数据中心领域看到了这一点。人们真的，你知道，这是一个AI治理和政策非常具体实在的领域，对吧？它存在于社区中。它关乎他们的水资源。
It is about their energy use. And it's where sort of AGI or superintelligence like lands on the ground. And it is where communities really feel they have a sense of agency around that. So we're seeing, I think I just saw in the news that Maine has banned, you know, data centers for a time. There's been, there were a lot of big projects announced that have been installed, that are being revisited. There's reporting now about. how a lot of these data center agreements in various communities were done with local politicians under NDAs, that local communities can't even know the terms of the agreement for some of these.
它关乎他们的能源使用。这就是AGI或超级智能落地的地方。这也是社区真正感受到他们对此拥有自主权的地方。所以我们看到，我想我刚在新闻里看到禁止数据中心一段时间。有很多公布的大型项目被搁置，正在重新评估。现在有报道称，许多社区中的这些数据中心协议是如何在保密协议下与当地政治家达成的，以至于当地社区甚至无法了解其中一些协议的条款。
And people are really pushing back against that. And they're pushing back against the harm to young people. They're very concerned about, you know, suicidal ideation and how chatbots encourage them. So am I optimistic about law? Absolutely not. But am I optimistic about the fact that it's getting much more difficult for, you know, companies and, you know, other elites who really want to just drive technology without thinking about the harms and the social implications to do that
人们正在强烈反对这一点。他们正在反对对年轻人的伤害。他们非常担心，你知道，自杀意念以及聊天机器人是如何鼓励这种意念的。所以我对法律持乐观态度吗？绝对不。但我对以下事实感到乐观吗，那就是对于公司和其他那些只想推动技术发展而不考虑危害和社会影响的精英来说，要做到这一点变得越来越困难了
because you've got a growing chorus of people, bipartisan, Roman, saying, maybe not aligned with bipartisan, you know, saying that, like, we don't want this. And so I find optimism, no encouragement, yes. I think one of the things, I just, my one point here is like, one of the things that I think it's funny is the biggest proponents of AI and the broad use of it are kind of the biggest fearmongers of it too. Like I think kind of enjoy the sort of sense of this is super powerful.
因为你有一群越来越多的两党民众，罗曼，他们说，也许并不完全与两党一致，但他们说，我们不想要这个。所以我找到了乐观，不，是鼓励，是的。我认为其中一件事，我只是，我在这里的一个观点是，我认为滑稽的一件事情是，AI的最大支持者和广泛使用它的推动者，同时也是它最大的恐慌制造者。就像我认为他们有点喜欢这种“这非常强大”的感觉。
You should let us do what we want to. And it's going to destroy humanity in five years. Like I think they like both of those things. So I think both of them like feed into their ego. They're both about power. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's fascinating because it's one of the things that the alarmists are the biggest proponents is a weird dynamic. This is not like tobacco regulation where we, you know, the people who wanted to like regulate were just on the side of harm and the other people were like no harm. It's an odd dynamic. And it's one of the things that's also like mixed up and all this stuff of like the Florida regulation versus the California regulation. The political valence of this stuff is much more complicated than most other things.
你们应该让我们做我们想做的事。而且它将在五年内毁灭人类。就像我认为他们同时喜欢这两件事一样。所以我觉得这两者都助长了它们的自负。它们都关乎权力。对。对。对。这很迷人，因为这是危言耸听者同时也是最大支持者的情况之一，这是一种奇怪的动态。这不像烟草监管，那些想要监管的人只站在反对伤害的一边，而其他人则说没有伤害。这是一个奇怪的动态。这也是让事情变得错综复杂的原因之一，比如佛罗里达州的监管与加利福尼亚州的监管。这些事情的政治倾向比大多数其他事情要复杂得多。
Yes, it's very complicated and kind of heterogeneous. And so that's fascinating. And I think there's some very interesting essays, articles, papers to be written about at a time of, you know, maybe historically, since we've been measuring highest polarization in American society, that you've got this growing negative sentiment about AI and that it's bipartisan and that the issue set about which people are having agreement of their dissatisfaction around is growing, right? So you go from kind of discrimination to young people and CSAM to fraud to, you know, healthcare. Like the space is just becoming much broader to data centers, for example. People obviously are worried about their jobs and worried about employment and what they're being told. Roman to your point about powerful people saying our powerful tool is going to be really great and destroy everything, including all of your jobs, right? So, yeah, it's a, you know, it's a very interesting.
是的，这非常复杂，而且有点异质性。所以这很吸引人。而且我认为有一些非常有趣的文章、论述、论文值得去写，在一个这样的时期，也许从历史上看，自从我们开始衡量美国社会中最高的两党对立以来，你发现人们对AI的负面情绪在不断增长，而且它是跨党派的，人们对之感到不满并达成共识的问题集正在扩大，对吧？所以从某种歧视扩大到年轻人和CSAM（儿童性虐待材料）、欺诈，再到，你知道，医疗保健。这个领域正在变得更加广泛，例如数据中心。人们显然担心他们的工作，担心就业以及他们被告知的事情。罗曼，正如你所说，权势人物说我们的强大工具将非常棒，并将摧毁一切，包括你们所有的工作，对吧？所以，是的，这是一个，你知道，非常有趣的。
interesting policy space, and it's a space, as I said, you know, I think of political encouragement, if not optimism. Yeah. I mean, this seems like a new opportunity for a different kind of alignment, which is really kind of fascinating. Yeah. Dr. Nelson, I really appreciate you being here. Thank you so much.
有趣的政策领域，而且正如我所说，这是一个让我感到政治上的鼓励（如果谈不上乐观的话）的领域。是的。我的意思是，这似乎是一个针对不同类型结盟的新机会，这确实挺吸引人的。是的。纳尔逊博士，非常感谢您来到这里。非常感谢。
It's been great to talk to you. So that's the original seven articles of the Constitution. Thank you for joining for all of that. Of course, there are amendments to be talked about, 27 of them. But we're going to take a pause on the breakdown of the Constitution. There's just so much going on with Trump and the Constitution that we're going to go back to releasing our what Trump can teach us about con law episodes. There won't be an episode in May, but we'll be back in June for Supreme Court decision season. Everyone's favorite season.
很高兴与您交谈。这就是宪法的最初七条。感谢大家收听所有这些内容。当然，还有需要讨论的修正案，总共27条。但我们将暂停对宪法的拆解。由于特朗普和宪法之间发生的事情实在太多，我们将恢复发布“特朗普能教给我们关于宪法法学什么”的节目。五月份不会有节目，但我们将在六月份最高法院判决季回归。每个人最喜欢的季节。
The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Constitution is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee, music by Swan Real, mixed by Martine. Gonzalez. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Loshamadonne, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered 6, Fox North in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown,
99%隐形宪法剖析由伊贝尔·安杰尔制作，委员会编辑，天鹅之实提供音乐，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·李、洛沙马多内、约瑟夫·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。99%隐形标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。该系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是天狼星XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大厦的6号福克斯北区。在美丽的上城区，
Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server where we have fun discussions about constitutional law, about architecture, about movies, music, all kinds of good stuff. You can find a link to the Discord server as well as every past episode of the Conlaw
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到这个节目，以及我们自己的Discord服务器，我们在那里就宪法、建筑、电影、音乐以及各种好东西进行有趣的讨论。你可以找到Discord服务器的链接，以及宪法法学的所有往期节目。
Book Club and every past episode of 99PI and 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
图书俱乐部以及99PI和99PI.org的所有往期节目。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。